former Republican Congressman will Hurd
is joining the ranks of Republicans
jumping into this 2024 presidential
primary is getting very very full my
file to be the Republican nominee for
president of the United States this is a
a decision that my wife and I decided to
do because we live in complicated times
and we need Common Sense there are a
number of generational defining
challenges that we're faced with in the
United States of America everything from
the Chinese government trying to surpass
us as the global superpower the fact
that inflation is persistent at a time
when Technologies like artificial
intelligence is going to upend every
single industry and our kids or their
their scores and math science and
reading are the lowest they've ever been
in this century